3.3 million veterans and counting
have served since 9/11.
Around three million have decided to
pursue higher education degrees.
Research from CUNY shows that
post-9/11 vets perform above
thenational average in most socio-economic categories.
Between 2005 and 2015, they had
higher employment rates
with median household incomes
higher than the national average.
However, over half of employers
believe that veterans don't pursue
a college or vocational degree
and that veterans don't have
successful careers after the military.
The media and the public erroneously believe that
the majority of post-9/11 vets
have a mental health disorder.
Unfortunately, since government-funded research prioritizes PTSD,
and since the preponderance of well-intentioned veteran legislation emphasizes mental health disorders,
the public, potential employers,
and veterans themselves
are trapped in the inaccurate and harmful broken veteran narrative.
This matters. In an all-volunteer force,
reputation is key to the attractiveness
of joining a profession.
How we publicly portray veterans relates to
how society conceptualizes military service.
Veterans are the unacknowledged permanent ambassadors of national service.
Do you think our veterans are misrepresented today in media and culture?
Why or why not? Let us know in your comments.
Also let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.